let's talk about number one that do a
friends reunion okay Oh
oMG I feel like we need to play that
again do a friends reunion okay oh no
your ears have not deceived you Jennifer
Aniston just told Ellen DeGeneres that
she's down to do a friends reunion oh
god listen I told you that I would do it
mm-hmm we have a lot of oh oh I know the
picture shows up I forget
the girls would do it yeah and the boys
would do it I'm sure listen
it's anything could happen even if even
if us even if someone can't do it yes
you can do it I can do it I can do it by
myself
you sure can those are and then got me
down I mean she can't just say that and
then not deliver and a reunion would be
perfect cuz there's also a major
milestone for the show coming up 25
years since friends first aired 25 years
in September since that show aired Wow I
know that's amazing isn't that crazy
and clearly Jen isn't the only one
feeling nostalgic lately Courtney Cox
posted this shot to Instagram last month
and like Jen said the cast does all seem
like they'd be down for a reunion series
of some sort you know we didn't write
the show I know and so you know I don't
know be so fun fun for us it's video it
was really fun being feeling the whole
thing was the best experience that I
could possibly imagine I felt very lucky
to have been a part of that show and
everything kind of seems to pale in
comparison whenever I read comedies I'm
I just like can't compare people are
still loving it now on Netflix it was
just funny all the way through all 237
episodes I knew it was gonna be the
happiest time of my life and it sort of
was it was just the it was just
everybody was young and creative and
just having a blast now the cast did get
together to pay tribute to their
director James burrows back in 2016 but
Matthew Perry was unable to make it in
person and it wasn't an episode of
friends just a gather
well it was just lovely to be in the
same room
[Applause]
alright guys what do we think could a
friends reunion reboot anything please
actually happen or is she just toying
with our emotions let me know what you
think and for all the latest on Jen and
the cast of friends keep it locked to
all things et until next time I'm Katie
Krauss and bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]